we are super bullish on Facebook two
billion daily active users so what is
the state of Facebook in 2023 what's the
opportunity is Facebook dead Facebook
wants the world to know hey our reels
format is really a main player in the
short form video of War if you will
all admit that even though you know
we're passionate about YouTube here we
are super bullish on Facebook we've been
seeing our Facebook reels blowing up and
so in this episode we're going to be
learning about all this new information
all these changes but let's kick it off
Mari Smith and uh welcome back to the
show thank you so much I'm happy to be
here before we jump into things what is
the state of Facebook right now there's
always Mark Zuckerberg released new
information how many people are active
on the platform and some people feel I
know that even some of our co-workers in
think media are like yeah I don't log
into Facebook I don't use Facebook
Facebook's dead I'm not using it is that
actually a fact what are the numbers
telling us hahaha it's not quite a fact
because it's easy to just pick up on the
hearsay and go you know I know a lot of
younger folks are maybe not logging on
that often and Facebook's for old people
like anybody over 30 and so then it's
like Facebook's dead but uh just at the
end of last year 2022 in the queue for
earnings call which was in February of
this year 23 Zuckerberg announced that
for the first time ever Facebook book
reached a new Milestone that they have 2
billion daily active users 2 billion
people around the planet logging on to
just the Facebook every day if you go
the whole Suite which is Messenger
WhatsApp and Instagram as well it's just
under 3 billion daily items it's crazy
yeah that's wild and that is absolutely
eclipsing all of the other platforms
that's right and a lot of platforms are
tracking even YouTube tracks monthly
active users but to think daily that
means that people's customers are there
Their audience the people they want to
reach and so the opportunity is pretty
massive well let's dive into some of
these features and these new tips well
let's kick it off with the thing that is
just blowing up on Facebook and we've
been experiencing this and that is
Facebook reels now we love vertical
video because of YouTube shorts and
we're seeing we can post it on to
Instagram into Tick Tock but we've been
posting Facebook reels on our pages and
we've been getting a couple hundred
views a couple thousand a couple hundred
thousand and we have a multiple million
viewed clips and this is shocking
because I think people are like I didn't
even know this was happening so what's
kind of the state of Facebook reels
right now well this is their attempt to
obviously directly compete head to head
with YouTube shorts and with the tick
tock reels and so they've been the
algorithms have been absolutely pushing
this format for for a long time and then
also what's happening is we've got this
AI powered discovery engine or
recommendation engine so about 20 of the
content that people see in their
Facebook feeds not just reels all types
of content is coming from people that
don't follow up pages that don't follow
people who don't know at all it's just
the AI is going hey Sean I actually know
you a lot better than you think you do
and you might like this and you might
like this so this is what's happening is
with these reels going viral is that all
it takes is a little bit of Engagement
to kind of like fire start that engine
and that AI powered discovery engine and
then it just can really take on a life
of its own and of course the algorithms
are really driving that because Facebook
wants the world to know hey our reels
format is really a main player in the
short form video kind of War if you will
and what's fascinating is this kind of
brings us to the second thing which is
this new professional mode on personal
pages so you can upload reels into
groups you can upload reels to your
business fan page that's right but now
there's this thing called professional
mode what is that okay so it's a
personal profiles where you can have up
to 5 000 friends and and ever since they
introduced the followers be subscriber
now it's followed for the longest time
but you can have unlimited number of
followers and that's they see your
content that you post to public so
Facebook rolled out at the end of 2021 a
new mode that aimed at creators that you
could choose to switch on it kind of
overlays on top of your personal profile
you still get your 5 000 friends but
they're kind of lumped in with your
however many followers you want and so
what I'm finding happening for a lot of
my audience members and clients when
they do choose to make that switch if
it's a fit if they're like a Creator
type an entrepreneur and influencers not
for everybody is yeah they are getting
significantly more reach and they get
access to insights to get access to all
the monetization tools subscriber
subscriptions to add Revenue share the
Stars they did have the rules plea bonus
program but that's been paused in the
U.S however honestly I switched to
professional mode in early 2022 when I
first got access and I saw this huge
lovely spike in reach and then it just
started to tape her off after about six
months so I actually chose to switch it
back to Classic after speaking to a
gentleman in my social scoop Facebook
group and he was like you know what I
went back to Classic and I saw way more
reach and I'm like really I'm doing the
same and same thing happened to me I got
more reach on classic wow so I think
what's exciting is this also an
opportunity though for some people maybe
they've never built up a fan page that's
right yeah yeah I have built up friends
and they have maybe a kind of a business
minded or something they want to promote
or now they are thinking content creator
personal brand and as you mentioned your
personal page if you are a business
brand you're probably not going to have
a personal page for that if you're a
non-profit you're not gonna have a
personal so it might not be relevant for
everyone but for personal Brands yes
that's something you could really lean
into and then you can upload reels among
other things text posts natively right
there to your personal page in
professional mode which is separate than
your fan page would be essential
absolutely it is yeah and I would
imagine at some point soon that Mata
business Suite is going to allow us
access to personal profile professional
mode uh enabled profiles to to schedule
and because right now you can't schedule
although they have it natively and it's
kind of comment and going is a little
bit buggy but you can do scheduling only
in the mobile app if you have
professional mode turned on but yeah it
can go crazy actually one of my clients
example she like yourselves went really
all in on the reels specifically on
their professional Mode Personal profile
and she went from something like a
thousand followers within 10 days she
had like 60 000 followers wow you know
and she got two million uh plays on one
of her reels that is amazing yeah yeah
and she's converting that to be fair
she's converting that to emails people
in our group dming people building
relationships getting sign ups for her
programs fascinating and so next up is
meta verified as we're going through
some of the opportunities that are
happening in the Facebook world meta of
course parent company of now Facebook
Instagram and other projects what is
meta verified well it's been rumored for
a while that you eventually might have
similar to Twitter blue or you've got
this paid Subscription Service you pay a
monthly fee and you get the blue check
verified badge and some other goodies I
look at this package of fan effects and
it seems somewhat cobbled together the
one obviously for those that covet the
blue badge they got that but then there
is apparently a little bit more reach
and it's only for personal profiles on
your Facebook and on your Instagram and
if you want to on both you have to pay
twice and it's like 15 bucks a month 10
or 12 or something if you pay through
the web only right now as of time of our
recording it is only in Australia New
Zealand one of the main benefits is you
get direct access to customer support
and so I actually uh heard a story a
gentleman who who had had his Facebook
ad account hacked a couple years ago and
he's in Australia the minute you go
access to meta verified within 24 hours
he got the service reach out to customer
support I'm not kidding within one hour
boom he had his ad account back his
business manager and an apology from
meta I'm like I hope that's a precedent
yeah wow yeah so for anybody some people
want it for The Branding and the
personal branding but for anybody who's
serious and investing in ads and using
meta in a serious way it's kind of a
no-brainer that you would invest in this
yes and because I've also heard like
from other folks saying oh no I heard
directly from meta that this is not for
business use I think that particular
gentleman out of Australia got lucky and
so it depends who you get when you reach
out for your customers support because
they're going to go oh no this is only
for personal but like we just spoke
about is if you've got ads on your
personal profile in professional mode
then you do have support for ads too
there yeah that's powerful another big
Facebook trend is AI what's happening in
that respect okay so Zuckerberg because
they have this new uh broadcast channel
it's called it's only an Instagram but
it's coming to Facebook and to messenger
where it's like a one-to-many way to
communicate with your audience so
Zuckerberg is really using his meta news
or something it's called and he put out
just the other week that they are
um have this new turbocharged focus on
AI like to turbocharge AI they're
bringing out AI personas as
I think it's basically like a version of
yourself that's well like your avatar
that can go and interact with other
avatars well we'll just hang out in the
beach I mean it's I saw a headline the
other day the the new
semi-automated social network is coming
LinkedIn are apparently Leading The Way
with that but it's like yeah it's where
they use some of the content is created
by Ai and then interactions are by Ai
and it's like wait are we are we taking
the humanity out of all this I don't
know well it is wild but I what I
predict is inside of meta business Suite
what meta will end up baking in there is
the ability to create content image
um text image and video and then and
then schedule it and you know what I
mean it's all going to just be baked
into the one the one app wow that's
fascinating and so uh next is groups as
even here at Social Media Marketing
World Michael selzner was mentioning uh
professional mode and personal pages and
some people are saying you know business
Pages reaches down is that where the new
reach is going to be what's happening in
groups what is your thought about that
level of thinking and are you bullish on
groups right now 100 I love groups I
love groups but the thing is that it
does take a while to really reach that
Tipping Point to the point where people
are so engaged they love it they
bookmark your group they come there they
post they they engage
um I have one as I mentioned called
social scoop and it's a great place for
marketers to really get a lot of peer
support I don't even necessarily post a
lot of content myself I'll do like
breaking news and then I'll break down
things that are happening there and I
often do that first anywhere else
um but yeah in my social media marketing
World talk I'm gonna showcase an example
where it's actually a chair cover coming
out of Ireland and they have a 32 000
people in this group and people are just
like geeking out over chair covers and
loving on each other and it's eventually
success story so when you find your
Niche and you find the flow of how to
build that into your marketing mix it
really can work well and so this is kind
of what you're saying it works if you
work it yes and these days Facebook is
in kind of it would seem like a Revival
like it seems like like there's some
momentum there and people were unsure
where it was going what's this whole
meta thing and but now there's all these
really cool breakout stories we're
hearing all these stories here but it is
leaning into a lot of things to learn a
lot of skill sets of course that's why
people follow you and they can continue
to stay up on on the edge of this but
are these what you mean when you say
kind of doing all the things having a
multi-prong strategy great question so
all the things in my my definition of
that is when I look at uh I do like I'm
audits I'll do an audit for my VIP
clients and I'll go in and I'll look at
pretty much their whole social media
presence but I'd love to see that they
always have an active story on their
Facebook page and that they're using
reels they're doing live streaming
they're doing short form video they're
maybe scheduling like scheduling a van
or scheduling alive in advance they've
got it connected up to multiple groups
they're changing up their cover image
regularly they're using those posts with
them colored background they're asking
questions they're getting decent
engagement and then I click in and I go
into their transparency and I can see
their running ad campaigns and not just
one or two but maybe you know several
dozen or more and that's what I mean
about all the things and then maybe
perhaps if it is a fit you go and you
convert your personal profile to
professional mode but that yeah all the
things everything Facebook throws at you
go for it I need to really lay down one
quick track here Sean is in the back of
my mind it's kind of bothering me that
and because I'm putting this in my
social media marketing talk is that we
we have to not allow ourselves to get so
pulled into this whole monetize your
content monetize your content be a
Creator be a Creator because it's not
for everybody it really isn't and so I'm
just so imploring my audience and
marketers and businesses to stay on
track with what's right for you and be
strategic but don't be like the puppet
on the string that Mada is going oh do
this do that and then you're like okay
that's the thing now it's like I'm back
think it through be strategic and you're
not chasing something like reals bonuses
or you're not just trying to jump on the
latest feature you're clear that what
are you selling do you have a product
who do you serve exactly and then use
the tools that support that and stay
focused and and whichever one of those
pieces is right for you you could
probably get away with not live
streaming but if you're doing everything
else or you could you know maybe you
don't post stories although I connect to
my Instagram stories to my Facebook
Stories and it allows me to do both yep
so uh that is super powerful which I
want to touch on just two more things
one was paid ads you mentioned paid ads
obviously here at Social Media Marketing
world the number one platform surveyed
of attendees here that people couldn't
live without is Facebook yeah and
especially if you have a product to sell
no question about it this is true I
think media we use meta Instagram and
Facebook ads that's it I mean we all
we've done Google display we've done
other things but like it's it is there's
so much opportunity there especially if
you're using it right is there anything
new on ads and how should especially
people that have a business have a
product how should they be thinking
about ads in 2023. ads I would say one
of the most popular units is these lead
ads they do really really well where
it's already a pre-populated form don't
get too crazy asking a lot of questions
unless you want like super super highly
qualified leads because that'll weed out
a lot of people that don't answer the
form questions but otherwise you can
just go like name and email maybe a
phone number if it's critical but you
can get a lot of decent leads where
people are already like oh that's my
name yep that's the email I want or they
can change it and then they get
repopulated once they fill it out so
it's also easy if they're interested in
what you're offering yeah well they just
hit the the ad and they'll just say it
might say like download or sign up and
they tap it and the next immediate
screen it works on mobile is they see
their name and emails already
pre-populated you know when the Facebook
first rolled it out they called it like
tap tap done you know tap yeah I want to
tap okay done and I'm going to the next
thing and I carry on scrolling you know
so but otherwise ads it's I you know I
often say I know enough about ads to be
dangerous it's not always my absolute
Forte but I definitely absolutely
encourage businesses to for example use
the a b testing feature inside of meta
business Suite because it's free and you
can do a lot of like your testing and
see what kind of posts work with your
audience just a small test organically
then you can go ahead and bet on the
winning horse and put some money behind
it in ads manager I love it and do you
think there is a use case for boosting
posts occasionally yeah there are but I
like to do inside of ads manager and not
just succumbing again there's Facebook
dangling that carrot you know this post
is doing well the 90 of your others give
us I don't know I see all kinds of crazy
stories get us 20 give us twenty dollars
and you can reach six more people like
wait what people post things like that
in my group I think the AI just got a
little drunk or something but it's like
yeah if you go into ads manager what you
can do then is actually a little bit of
split testing with that boosted post
where you can't really do that if you
just use the really it's a kind of a
lightweight interface uh just just a
straight boost button I love it okay and
then you also mentioned messenger which
has been a separate app is coming back
to the Facebook app again to be
integrated in what's the implication to
that so seven years ago much to the
complete annoyance of all of us Facebook
broke off the messenger app and now we
had to download this extra app and it
was really frustrating at the time now
what happened so is it turns out that
between Facebook and Instagram something
like a billion reels a day are shared
privately in DMS and so you know
Zuckerberg and crew are going hmm all
right what if we reintegrated re-bake
that into the main app to make it just
much much easier one tap share and you
carry on your scrolling so they're doing
a little test right now as of time of
recording and the implications are
they're going to be rolling it out more
widely presumably they have some really
you know solid infrastructure in the app
these days because that was one main
reason they broke it off is to make it a
little bit lighter but it's coming back
it follow their tasks go well and the
main implication is doing these private
sharings of reels that's amazing well
Marty Smith you shared so much
information and of course it's exciting
because the opportunity for those that
want to get their message out there
Reach people build their brand build
their business leaning in on Facebook
and with so many with a billion active
users a day it's like your target
audience is there two billion active
users every single day yep active users
too and you know I think uh the latest
numbers on YouTube is 2.6 billion
monthly so that's a one out of so you're
saying two million a day it's massively
attention exactly
users yeah exactly per day or in
Facebook that's right that's a massive
number of people and of course you know
you want to reach somebody get your
message there and so that's a lot to
learn and so how can people follow you
and of course we'll list everything out
in the show notes but uh yeah check out
your stuff and some of the ways you are
helping people yeah yeah just my
Facebook page Marty Smith and the group
right there is hooked up Mario Smith
social scoop Instagram Marian underscore
Smith and marismith.com so yeah thanks
thanks Sean the queen of Facebook Marty
Smith I think media podcast